Now that the movie's in theaters, Birds of
Prey fans can finally dig into the film's
massive ensemble, twisted set pieces, and
inventive action.
With so much going on, it can be easy to miss
all the plot developments or know where everyone
stands by the end.
We're here to help.
"We're gonna have to work together."
Birds of Prey's subtitle touts the film as
the story of Harley Quinn's "fantabulous emancipation,"
and it is.
Harley starts the film as an emotional wreck
prone to binge drinking, crying jags, and
blowing up chemical plants.
That all changes when she gains a chance to
earn her freedom from her bad reputation and
bonds with the rest of the Birds of Prey team.
By the end of the film, she's got a new protege
in Cassandra Cain, a new probably-not-legal
business and a new reputation as someone who
can get things done.
But the grenade-explosion death of Roman Sionis
doesn't necessarily mean all of Harley's trouble
is about to go away.
She used to roll with the Joker, after all,
and no matter how far she gets from that relationship
there's someone, somewhere, looking to cause
her pain for her past sins.
Harley is smart enough to know this, and she'll
no doubt be looking over her shoulder for
the next great threat.
When we first meet Cassandra Cain, she's a
low-level pickpocket who wanders the streets
of Gotham trying to avoid going back to the
crappy apartment where her parents are constantly
fighting.
Over the course of the film, she goes on a
massive adventure, becomes the focus of a
citywide scavenger hunt, and finds a new big
sister figure in the form of Harley Quinn.
Cassandra's got a whole new life ahead of
her as Harley's protege.
What does she do now?
The possibilities seem endless, considering
who she's hanging out with, but one path seems
very likely.
Yes, the film version of Cassandra is very
different from the comics, but we do know
that comics Cassandra took on the role of
Batgirl for a while.
It would take a few years and a little training,
but perhaps movie Cassandra could also pull
that off.
Detective Renee Montoya starts the film as
a rough-edged, determined, smart Gotham City
cop with a tendency toward alcoholism and
deep resentment toward her mostly-male colleagues
for taking promotions she deserved.
By the end, she's not exactly a new woman,
but she does seem to have renewed purpose.
The vigilante life will allow her to do the
kind of good in Gotham that she never could
with a badge.
Renee becomes a founding member of the Birds
of Prey alongside her new friends Helena Bertinelli
and Dinah Lance,
cementing her place as a crime fighter outside
the realm of the law.
Her old cop connections will no doubt make
her very good at that job, but it's not necessarily
the end of Renee's evolution.
Longtime DC Comics readers know Renee eventually
became the new incarnation of masked vigilante
the Question, a transition we could still
see on the big screen someday.
Black Canary is something of a mystery.
When we meet her, she's a lounge singer at
Black Mask's club, doing whatever she can
to get by.
But then she displays tremendous fighting
abilities as well as her supersonic "Canary
Cry," which lets us all know that she's got
gifts she's been keeping under wraps.
What the film doesn't tell us is how and why
Canary is so gifted, which means her backstory
is ripe for exploration in future films.
With Canary now one of Gotham City's most
visible vigilantes, and there's nowhere to
go but up.
In upcoming films, we could certainly see
her comic book love interest Green Arrow one
day, though a version of the Canary/Arrow
dynamic did just recently play out on the
small screen for eight seasons.
Helena Bertinelli seems like the most straightforward
character in the title team, because she seems
to have only one real motivation: Avenge the
deaths of her family members by killing everyone
tied to it.
When she finally kills the last person she
believes to be involved in the massacre, Victor
Zsasz, Helena has to find something else to
live for.
"Psychologically speaking, vengeance rarely
brings the catharsis we hope for."
By the end of the film, Helena may not have
shed any of the leftover awkwardness from
her single-minded pursuits as the Huntress,
but she has gained a broader perspective of
the world.
As Renee Montoya noted, she's fooling herself
if she thinks the symptoms of the problem
that killed her family stopped with the last
name on her list.
Now, as a member of the Birds of Prey, she
has a new outlet for making the world a better
place, and stopping the deaths of other families
in the process, using her regained inheritance
to fund the whole operation.
Birds of Prey sets up Roman Sionis, a.k.a.
Black Mask, as a true Big Bad worthy of Harley's
fear.
Roman is a truly terrifying, unhinged mob
boss who seems to have bought and killed his
way to the top, to the point that by the end
of the film, he basically has an army at his
beck and call.
Plus, we know that a lot of what he's done
in the past means very few mob leaders are
fit to challenge him, and those that do find
themselves without faces.
But by the end of the film, Gotham's most
powerful mob boss has been blown to bits on
Founders Pier.
His right-hand man is also dead, and there's
suddenly a very prominent power vacuum in
Gotham's underworld.
So, who's going to rise up and fill that void?
There are a lot of candidates who could step
up, particularly with the Joker seemingly
out of the picture.
Perhaps it's time for the Penguin to become
the big-screen crime lord we've all been waiting
to see.
Much like the Joker, Batman doesn't appear
in Birds of Prey, but his presence is felt
nonetheless.
Harley references him as part of her origin
story, noting he arrested her after she helped
Joker break out of Arkham Asylum.
He's often either the butt of Harley's jokes
or serves as a reminder that Harley still
remembers her encounters with him.
He's also brought up in subtler ways.
For one thing, Harley Quinn's pet hyena is
named Bruce, and she's so proud of that name
that she wears it on a chain around her neck.
He's named after billionaire playboy Bruce
Wayne...
"I named him Bruce after that hunky Wayne
guy."
...so does Harley know that Bruce Wayne is
Batman?
Then there's the post-credits audio snippet,
in which Harley promises to tell us a secret.
She gets as far as saying "Batman f-" before
the audio cuts out.
Given her hyena's name could one assume Harley
is sweet on the Batman?
We may never know, but it's fun to think about.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the DC
movie universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.